[Music]
you have no family
you have no friends
you are abused until you gave yourself
to me
how you have a purpose and it is Noble
she's your field agent do what you
think's best I have to be sure
she's able to make contact with the
target
what are her directives then neutral
light Target
Mr President we have a situation
unfolding in real time are you close
closer than we've ever been you're
completely Outside the Lines burning a
different job man
if your cover is blown there is no
saving you you have to save yourself do
it quiet and you do it clean be careful
Pokemon there where the target will be
on you
studies embedded mission is launched we
can't stop it now
one finds out it'll end up in the news
this is our mess we clean it up how do
we shut this down
I need you to understand the risks
[Music]
understand the risk
thank you
[Music]